inside these doors is littering
Aladdin's Cave nelson mandela's life
there's everything from the number 6
rugby shirt he wore when the Springboks
won the World Cup back in 1995 a year
after he'd become president there are
shelves just stacked with the awards he
won over 700 or was presented with over
700 of awards and medals and doctorates
from around the world and here just some
of the thousands of photographs and
pictures that were done of him presented
to him that he SAT for that give you a
flavor of this extraordinary man's life
well inside these huge vault in the
archive there are some real surprises
I'm here Nelson Mandela had his own
replica of the football world cup
presented when it was staged here in
2010 there's a cricket bat signed by
Brian Lara saying a man that has
inspired the world i love you president
mandela my best wishes to my personal
hero there are boxing gloves there are
sports wear that has been dedicated to
them there is everything that gives you
a flavour of just what esteem he's been
held in by the world at large while I'm
here this really is the inner sanctum
I'm here with Rizzio is the chief
archivist so you're the keeper of the
real treasures what have you got here
for us this is I think the very first
sort of known document relating to
Mandela isn't it yes this membership
card is from nineteen twenty nine when
Madiba was about 11 years old it's a
membership card to the sunday school of
the methodist church we don't have a
birth certificate to anything earlier
than nineteen twenty nine this is him at
school and this is a little bit more
grown up this is what late teens this is
Model S 1938 this is a hill town school
where he attended as a boarder and
that's him in the background there
wasn't in the background for much of his
life hey I'm moving on to the time he'd
become an active
these are the first the first known
pictures of him actually at Robben
Island yes in 1977 there was speculation
that us I have a very ill or that he had
passed on so the party government
organized a visit of the media to Robben
Island and on that day they were told
not to go and work in the quarry but to
work in the garden so he was taken by
surprise and you can see from this
expression in this photo that is not
very happy and we have a letter of him
complaining about being put on display
interesting you've got documents that he
wrote when he was in prison tell us more
about this these are not we have two of
these notebooks it's a trust of letters
that he wrote when he was on the island
in the initial years he was only allowed
500 words every six months it was a
really remarkably good record of
everything he thought and roads in
prison yes I think we're quite fortunate
that you are such a meticulous record
keeper with a set of letters when his
son died while he was in Robben Island
so he's writing to winnie mandela who
was his wife at the time the mother of
his son Evelyn his first wife and then
he writes to his other son and to the
prison authorities informing them about
the death of his son died but he wasn't
allowed to go to the funeral yes no you
wasn't allowed to go to the funerals
it's quite emotional his letters
reflexes pain and not being able to
attend his mother's funeral his son's
funeral so you should go through a lot
of the letters you can feel his pain
that is going through makes one very
teary eyed as interesting you've got his
very first real genuine legal passport
here which he didn't get until after
he'd come out of jail after is released
so this is his first ever legal passport
any credit a few days after his release
one of the places he went to of course
was Oslo to collect the Nobel Peace
Prize and I imagine that's one of the
most prized exhibits here isn't it yes
a lot of people love to see the medal
it's it's yeah it's really precious I
think it's about ensuring that the
memory becomes a resource to continuing
struggles for justice and of course
whether you're talking about South
Africa specifically or but the world
where we are as a human project there's
a lot of work to be done it's presumably
a never-ending job this isn't it well
it's it's probably the fundamental
lesson that he taught us is that the
long walk to freedom never ends not far
from the archives themselves was Nelson
Mandela's own personal space he's
private office that he worked in almost
every day until ill-health took over
around three years ago and it is where
you find his own private and personal
memories some extraordinary memorabilia
here apart from all his favorite books
as a policeman's helmet from the
Metropolitan Police in London there are
photographs of him with friends and
family and world leaders one of them
here the first time he met Barack Obama
just before he'd become American
president there is a picture here as
well of him and Muhammad Ali they became
very close friends and of course had one
thing big in common boxing that Nelson
Mandela loved the box when he was young
the walls are covered in photographs
perhaps none more poignant than this one
it's a photograph of the two sons that
pre-deceased him one who died aged 25 in
a road crash at a time when Nelson
Mandela was in Robben Island jail and
wrote to the governor to try and get out
to go to the funeral but wasn't allowed
to something that he described as
inhumane the other son died a few years
ago of AIDS and it's a photograph that
Nelson Mandela cherished having on his
walls here on a lighter side a reminder
that cowls play a big part in tribal
life in South Africa and Nelson Mandela
love to sit in his homestead down in
kunu
trans guy homeland and watch the cows on
the fields outside this office is not
only full of memories of Nelson Mandela
it also brings back memories for me
because it was in this place around five
years ago that I last SAT and chatted to
Nelson Mandela the man I'd known when I
was a correspondent in South Africa the
man I'd seen come out of jail and make
that long journey to becoming president
I'll never forget our chat here or our
final walk together in South Africa